字幕: Yoshimi Takenaka
校正: Hiroko Kawano
いきなりですが
この中で 肩こりですごく
困っているという人
手を挙げてください
結構いますね
じゃあ 肩こりの人
こんな感じで肩を揉んでみてください
中には痛いとか 痛気持ちいいとか
中には 気持ちいいという人も
いるかもしれませんが
その感じをちょっと覚えておいてください
はい 手を下ろしていいですよ
この肩こりなんですけど
原因としては 色々あります
パソコンの使い過ぎとか
スマホの見過ぎとか
中には骨盤が曲がっているとか
ストレートネックがどうのこうのとか
色んなことがありますけれども
私は理学療法士です
今まで 何百人何千人
という人を診てきました
その中でも 肩こりがひどい
という人は 特になんですけど
病院で湿布をもらっても
なかなか治らないんですよね これが
薬をもらったんだけれども
あんまり薬に頼りたくない
カイロでボキボキッと
やってもらったんだけども
マッサージでグリグリッと
やってもらったけども
次の日になったら またこっていると
お金もかかるし 時間もかかるし
どうしてくれるんだと
そういう話をよく聞きます
実は 肩こりの原因と解決法というのは
結構 簡単なものだったんですね
それを今日 皆さんに
シェアしたいと思います
まず説明の仕方なんですけども
ちょっと難しい
専門用語を使った説明の仕方と
小学生でもわかる簡単な方法と
どっちがいいですか？
小学生？
はいオーケーです
じゃあそれでいきましょう
単純に言って
原因はストレスです
まあ ストレスといっても
２通りあるんですけども
身体的なストレス
病気とかケガなんていうのは
重い 結構大きいストレスですね
あと運動することもストレスだし
運動不足というのもストレスです
よく デスクワークが多い人は
結構ストレスを感じているかもしれません
もう１つは 精神的なストレス
精神的なストレスというは
学校とか会社での人間関係
彼女とかの何か色々
ごたごたってありますね
あと
仕事でいうと締め切りとか
学校で試験とか
そういうプレッシャーが
結構ストレスになってきます
実際私が ここに立って話しているのも
かなり精神的・身体的な
ストレスがかかっています
今 私の体では
心臓がバクバクバクバクいってます
手に汗握って
口もすごい乾いているんですけど
呼吸の数も 普段の10倍ぐらいです
だんだん肩もこってきました
これっていうのは でも
ストレスにちゃんと体が
対応してますよっていう証拠なんですね
今さっき 肩こりがあるって
言っていましたけども
人間がストレスに対応する時に
空気の入れ替えを
どんどんしなければならない
そういう時に
一番手っ取り早いっていうのが
肩で息をするんですね
例えば 電車に乗りたい 間に合わない
階段をダッシュでバーッと走って
もうギリギリセーフで乗れた時
みんな肩で息をしてますよね
こんな感じで
覚えがありますか？
はい そんな感じで
空気が早く必要な時には
肩で息をするんです
そうすると 肩を動かすには
この肩の筋肉を使いますね
肩の筋肉と首の筋肉を使って
胸を上げて肺を膨らまそうとする
だから肩がこる そういうわけです
でもこれ一時的なものだといいんですけど
これがずっと継続的に続くと
色んなストレスが毎日来て
いつも肩で呼吸をしていると
そうすると体が 私の体は
呼吸する時はもう肩でするものだと
というわけで
肩がどんどん使われて
肩がこっていくと
そういうわけなんです
いいですか？ 大丈夫ですか？
はいそれで どうすればいいか？
ストレスを取り除こうって
まあできませんね 色々あるので
じゃあ息をして肩がこるなら
息を止めればいいんじゃないかと
そんなことをしたら死んじゃうんで
それもできません
じゃあ どうすればいいか？
それを今 皆さんに教えたいと思います
じゃあ皆さん１回 立ってください
ああ いいですねえ
やっとみんなが見える
はい そしたら
思いっきり深呼吸してください
はい息吸って
はい吐いて ハ～
はい息吸って もう１回吸って
はい ちょっと
そこで止めてください
今 肩の位置どこですか？
みんな上がってますね
ストレス感じてるんですか？
はい息吐いて リラックスしてください
みんなは こうやって
肩で息をしてるんですね
だから次は
お腹の横隔膜という筋肉があるので
そこを使って呼吸をしてみましょう
じゃあ皆さん お腹に手をつけてください
そして まずお腹を膨らませながら
鼻から息を吸います
はい吸って お腹を膨らまして
吐いて ハ～
肩はしっかり下げておいてくださいね
はい では鼻から息を吸って
お腹をいっぱい膨らます
で 吐く
まだちょっと肩が動いている人がいますね
はいお腹にいっぱい吸って
で 吐く
もうちょっと長く吐いてください
はい もう１回吸って
鼻から吸って
はい 吐いて
はいリラックス
いいですね
そしたら さっき
まだ肩こりがあるっていう人
さっき肩こりがあるって言った人
手を挙げてください
またこんな感じで また揉んでみてください
どうですか？
個人差はあると思いますが
少し感じが変わったと思います
はい 手を下ろしていいですよ
ところで
でもこんな簡単に
肩こりが治っていいんですかと
いや大丈夫ですよ
ちゃんと治るんですよ
じゃあ これを朝と夜
毎日やってください
寝ながらでいいですよ
ああそうですか
それはなかなか粋（息）な方法だ
ありがとうございました
（笑）
（拍手）